hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a Russian apocalyptic
Thriller show called the day after
spoilers ahead watch out ants take care
[Music]
the show opens up with an advertisement
mentioning that humans should be given a
second chance it then talks about a
pharmaceutical company called Pinnacle
corporation that is apparently helping
the world become a better place
following this the scene shifts to an
underground bunker-like place where a
bunch of people are lying on the floor
soon two of them Irina and Pasha wake up
they have no recollection of the past or
how they ended up there to make this
situation more creepy they find other
unconscious humans lying around the
place terrified Irina and Pasha try to
find a way out of the place but to no
avail suddenly the other humans also
regain Consciousness even they have no
idea how they ended up here that must
have been one hell of a New Year's party
while trying to locate a way out of the
place two other people Natasha and Sasha
enter the bathroom and find a guy hiding
inside he introduces himself as nerd and
starts laughing like a maniac saying
they are going to die soon shortly after
a fierce young man Valera asks all 11
people to gather around and try to
remember the moment just before their
kidnapping Natasha mentions that she was
having a normal day with her family and
friends the very next thing she
remembers is waking up in this desolate
place as the discussion goes on nerd
notices a camera in the room and tells
everyone that they are being watched
elsewhere in the busy streets an old man
Mr randomsky can be seen speaking over
the phone with someone asking them to
leave the city as soon as possible later
he receives a call from a random number
informing him that his daughter has been
kidnapped and is in danger randomsky is
then asked to arrive in the lab within
an hour if he wants to see his daughter
alive having no other choice he agrees
back in the underground bunker Sasha and
Irina find some old photographs of
doctors and to deduce that the place
used to be a research lab or probably an
operation theater or maybe a place for
sex parties at the same time Pasha nerd
and another guy mitia enter the cold
storage room and find a lot of powdered
food there this makes mitia realize that
whoever brought them here is planning on
keeping them for a long time however
nerd being a pessimist asserts that the
food is being poisoned to test the
theory michia brings the food to the
other room and places it on the table
Valera immediately picks it up and
starts eating it when mitia sees that
the food is showing no side effects on
Valera he too joins in and starts eating
some corn Puffs meanwhile Sasha and
Irina are searching for the operation
theater and it looks like they have
found it they open a hidden door and
inside find an operation bed with some
tools and belongings of a child nearby
Irina who seems to be a surgeon
immediately recognizes the tools and
informs the others that they are used to
amputate body parts after a while
everyone leaves the room but nerd along
with a mischievous guy zenya continue
their investigation nerd tries to smell
a suspicious powder from the table but
zenya blows on it and sprays the powder
all over nerd's face this suffocates the
latter causing him to cough profusely to
make the situation worse zenya walks out
of the room and closes the door trapping
nerd inside fortunately Irina and
Natasha arrive just in time and open the
door at this point nerd is coughing up
blood and suffocating horribly seeing
his condition all of them are terrified
and start blaming the mischievous zenya
elsewhere as radomski is being taken
away in a van he suddenly attacks the
guards resulting in a minor brawl during
the commotion an important vial kept
inside a box rolls over and falls into a
hole then it collides with a fan and
breaks the contents of the vial start
flowing until it reaches a railway
station where a lot of people are
waiting for their train to arrive
surprisingly all of them start losing
their senses and fall to the ground one
by one in the next scene a News Channel
reports that an unknown substance has
been spilled at a station causing
thousands of people to suffer from
symptoms like high fever and poor
eyesight it also mentions that the
mortality rate of the disease is high
and that the government is trying its
best to keep it under control meanwhile
inside the Pinnacle Corporation
Headquarters an employee enters the CEO
Mr glotov's office and informs him about
the Escape of rendomsky he also mentions
that the virus inside the vial they were
after has been destroyed and people
around the City are suffering from it
enraged glow top yells at the employee
and asks him to find randomsky at any
cost he also mentions that the
information about their secret project
Clayton should not get leaked
furthermore no one should know about the
Pinnacle corporation which experiments
on genetic mutations and ravages the
city with viruses elsewhere Sasha
continues searching around the bunker
and finds some photographs where the
doctors are wearing aprons containing
the logo of the Pinnacle Corporation
seeing this he immediately calls the
others to the room and tries to make
them understand that they are being
trapped by Pinnacle for some reason
Sasha also talks about project Clayton
which he found while he and his team
tried to hack the main servers of the
Corp sadly none of them believe in his
words and walk away what reason could
they possibly have not to believe him on
the other hand we see the whole city
being evacuated while randomsky roams
around the streets still alive at the
Pinnacle corporation's office glotov's
employee reveals that the virus does not
seem to affect young women and that it
will be ineffective after a day day
hearing this glotov asks it to shut down
all communication networks in all of
Moscow later randomsky arrives at an
evacuation spot and tries to get the
attention of an officer he reveals that
he is one of the creators of the virus
and that the Pinnacle Corporation is
behind all of this unfortunately the
officer does not listen to him as he is
busy evacuating the place when randomsky
continues insisting that he's telling
the truth he is apprehended for
disturbing the officers meanwhile nerd
who is resting in the so-called bedroom
suddenly gets a vision of the doctors
trying to perform an experiment on him
as Marina was talking to a nurse in his
vision nerd assumes that she is a spy
who is leaking their information to the
bad guys hence he approaches Marina
holds her at knife point and asks her to
reveal the truth despite everyone asking
him to leave her alone nerd does not
listen and simply keeps saying that
Marina is helping the doctors to conduct
their experiments fortunately before he
could harm Marina metia cleverly grabs
his knife from behind and beats him to a
pop after the incident nerd is taken to
the other room and tied up while Irena
treats his wounds she inquires if he
wants some water but nerd who has
started becoming paranoid says that she
is also a spy who just wants to poison
him later while everyone is discussing
what to do with nerd the stylish and
arrogant Lady of the group Nadia
suggests they kill him she claims that
nerd might have been infected by a
contagious disease and that's why he's
been acting so weird a few of them agree
but Irina Sasha and Natasha completely
shun the idea shortly after when Marina
heads to the bedroom she finds nerd in
an unresponsive condition terrified she
screams for help and informs everyone
about the situation Irina immediately
rushes inside and tries to perform CPR
on him but to no avail everyone realizes
that he has died and walks out of the
room sadly R.I.P Get Wrecked nerd
shortly after the alpha male of the
group Valera mentions that if they want
to get out of this place alive they have
to act fast for the first step He
suggests that They smash the CCTV
cameras and convey their messages to the
people who are keeping them hostage the
entire group agrees with the decisions
so they start breaking all the cameras
one after another now they are all
waiting for a response meanwhile a boy
can be seen driving his car and
approaching the border of the city when
he tries to enter the city a group of
army officers stop him and ask him to
return however he refuses claiming that
his sister is trapped inside and so he
has to rescue her when the officers once
again refuse him the boy returns to his
car drives it at full speed and breaks
the barrier to enter the city on the
other hand a middle-aged man named
Sergey hears randomsky screaming for
help and comes to his rescue the latter
is finally released but he still has the
handcuffs on him nonetheless the two
walkouts slide together and witness the
destruction around the city with dead
bodies lying in the middle of the
streets after a while Sergey spots a bar
and suggests they check it out inside he
serves a drink to randomsky and tries to
open his handcuffs with a cork remover
in the following scene the boy who broke
the Border barrier earlier Max stops his
car in front of a building and rushes
inside of it to search for his sister he
knocks on the apartment door but doesn't
not get any answer hence he leaves the
building and enters the nearby hospital
where Irina used to work after walking
around for a bit Max spots a doctor
running away from a surgery room he
quickly approaches the doctor and
inquires about his sister however rather
than answering his question the doctor
reveals that he is infected and asks Max
to stay away from him saying this he
injects himself with a syringe and dies
on the spot back in the underground
bunker the group decides to store nerds
corpse inside the freezer after they do
so Irina places a cloth over his face
and sits beside the corpse she is still
distraught over the fact that she
couldn't save nerd seeing her in this
state mitia approaches her and tries to
make her understand that it wasn't her
fault that nerd died he also mentions
that people are born to die and that
it's a natural process as the two are
deeply immersed in their conversation
the door of the freezer automatically
closes and they are trapped inside Irina
and mitia scream for help but no one can
hear them realizing that they're going
to freeze to death metija suggests that
they hug each other to keep themselves
warm Irena agrees without any hesitation
in the too cozy app one thing leads to
another and they are about to kiss but
just then Pasha opens the door looking
for food meanwhile mitia rushes to
confront zenya assuming that he is the
one who locked them in the freezer as
expected the latter denies it but mitcha
is not going to let up so easily he
gathers everyone around a table and
tries to find out the real culprit
during their discussion Valera mentions
that someone among them is a snitch who
is transmitting information to the
people who trapped them there hearing
this Nadia adds that whosoever is the
snitch must be a skilled person as the
kidnappers wouldn't just hire a useless
person she then looks around the table
and points at Irena saying that she is
the smartest one amongst them she can
perform experiments and surgeries
something which would be of great
importance to the kidnappers hearing
this the entire group turns on her and
inquires a better past but Irina refuses
to speak and walks away adding more fuel
to the already existing suspicion she
locked herself in the freezer so that
she could bone mitcha yeah the scene
then shifts to the bar where randomsky
wakes up from his hangover Sergey is
nowhere to be found but it is revealed
that he has managed to take off the
handcuffs after a while randomski begins
searching for Sergey only to find him
lying dead in the kitchen it turns out
he was already infected with the virus
back in the underground bunker mitia
confronts Nadia inside the bathroom and
asks for some narcotics when she refuses
to have any he grabs her by the neck and
kisses her following this the two start
undressing and get intimate unbeknownst
to the fact that zenya is filming all of
this hiding inside one of the toilets
later while everyone is busy discussing
Nadia arrives there wearing a towel and
attacks zenya suspecting that he is the
one who turned off the shower right then
Natasha emerges from the other room and
informs everyone that there is no water
in the bunker even the freezer has been
turned off terrified they quickly
collect the remaining bottles of water
and walk out of the freezer elsewhere we
see a group of high-ranking officials
discussing the city situation they are
regretting the fact that they handed
over their top secret project Clayton to
glotov back at the bunker the group
gathers around the table and tries to
ration the remaining bottles of water
however Valera becomes aggressive and
tells everyone that from now on he will
be in charge of the food and water
supplies as everyone there stares at him
in Anger Pasha concludes that they are
getting punished for smashing the
cameras that can't be it how would they
even know that they smashed the cameras
stupid wasting no time Sasha and zenya
start repairing a camera and eventually
succeed they then try to ask their
kidnappers to turn on the freezer and
also the water supply unfortunately
rather than listening to their requests
a loud irritating noise is played in the
bunker compelling them to cut all the
electric wires meanwhile Sasha puts his
hand over the bathroom's ventilation and
deduces that the air supply has also
been cut off elsewhere as rendomski is
searching for his daughter around the
place Max runs into him and together
they hide inside a building once they
reach a safe location randomski reveals
that he is one of the scientists who
created the virus he was pressured by a
group of evil men whose only agenda was
power and wealth randomski then pleads
with Max to help him find his daughter
but the boy refuses saying he doesn't
help terrorists in the next scene glotov
meets with the high-ranking officials
and apologizes for his mistake he also
lies to them that randomski is already
dead glotov then assures the officials
that he is very serious about their
mission and that he can never betray
them saying this he walks away but not
before telling the officials to make a
decision on his future meanwhile
desperate to get out of the bunker
Valera starts Scavenging through the
storage room to find something useful
eventually he finds some materials that
could help him prepare a bomb Valera
then approaches the other group members
and explains his plan he wants to use
the bomb to blow up one of the exit
doors although the mission is a
dangerous one the group is willing to
take the risk so they agree with this
Valera along with the help of Zenia
starts preparing the bomb right then the
radio transmitter in the room starts
working a man narrates that the virus
has ruined the entire city thousands of
people have died and millions more are
infected this shocks everyone in the
room and even believe that the
underground bunker is a boon to them
nonetheless they continue with the bomb
experiment and fit it on one of the
Bunker's exit doors the episode ends
with Valera sticking a cigarette to
light up the bomb and everyone else
waiting for it to explode we're going to
continue this one in series recapped so
be sure to check it out